you
yeah meanwhile feruzia just puts the
queen on a nice safe square just keep
her on dark squares keep her away from
the white rook and
i have no hope now for our time of okay
he goes after arnold the a pawn but
that pawn is even defended and that's
the scary thing when you're facing a
queen when you kind of
ruin the coordination between your
pieces now the white rook on one side
the white king on the other side it
feels like the correct check and the
white rook will drop off but feruzia is
about to win actually by direct
checkmate the white king's been forced
all the way to the corner and it's that
e pawn that central pawn that's about to
become a new queen and that is going to
cause artemis to resign there we go
forusia takes the point wow impressive
stuff by the 18 year old give us a smile
what a fantastic result alright of
rouzia with the black pieces he's taking
the lead right now in the match against
vladislav our tamiyam how impressed are
you nowhere again by this fantastic 18
year old yeah he's you know showing that
when it comes to aggressive attacking
play and spotting those neat tactics he
is the man for the job i mean
what a bolt from the blue that he had
against artemyev that was highly in